deux agents de la sncf inculpé
d'homicide et de blessures involontaires
dans la catastrophe de la gare de lyon
c'était il ya quinze jours à l'accident
avait fait rappelez-vous 56 morts les
deux inculpés sont le conducteur du
train percute heures et celui qui
veillait à la fermeture des portes du
train a percuté les deux inculpations
indigne bien sûr les syndicats de
cheminots agnès poirier 56 morts pour un
enchaînement de circonstances c'est ce
qu'avaient conclu la commission d'
enquête le 27 juin 88 une passagère tire
le signal d'alarmé dans le train melun
paris
la ram s'immobilise en gare de vert de
maisons quand le mécanicien redémarre
vers la gare de lyon ils croient les
freins desserré en fait la conduite
générale de pression les freins a été
fermée par mégarde
seuls les freins de la motrice vérifié
par le mécanicien répondent encore s'il
avait suivi les recommandations du guide
de dépannage précise le rapport d'
enquête
il aurait pu faire face à la situation
de ce texte touchant à la sécurité est
précisément mal écrit difficile à
interpréter précise la commission
denquête le train des vannes vers la
gare de lyon le mécanicien lance un
appel radio aux aiguilleurs et ordonne
aux voyageurs de se réfugier au fond de
la ram c'est le choc
à plus de 70 km heure le train percute
un autre convoi de voyageurs convoi qui
aurait dû être parti depuis deux minutes
mais le contrôleur chargé de veiller à
la bonne fermeture des portes avait pris
du retard dans son service
al'annonce de l'inculpation du
mécanicien du train percuteur et du
contrôleur du train à l'arrêt et
syndicats se sont indignées ou six
responsables il ya c'est la direction de
la sncf et les pouvoirs publics tout
seul tout seul parce que la politique
qui est menée depuis des années et qu'on
a appelée nous la politique de risque
calculé c'est bien la direction les bois
public il amène ce sont pas les
cheminots eux ils la subissent
en signe de protestation une grève
quelques heures à l'appel de la cfdt
risque demain la gare de lyon dé
perturber le trafic
[Musique]